Alemania enviará 14 tanques leopardos a
Ucrania según medios locales
Es la primera vez que Berlín autoriza el
envío de estos vehículos militares que
por su naturaleza armamentística
diseñados para alcanzar objetivos de
hasta 5 kilómetros están destinados a
operaciones ofensivas y no defensivas lo
que representa un cambio de estrategia
significativo de los países europeos en
la Guerra de Ucrania que ya cumple 11
meses
esta decisión Del canciller Olaf shows
era esperada por el presidente ucraniano
bolodimir selenski desde finales del año
pasado cuando las tropas de kiev
comenzaron una exitosa contraofensiva en
el este y sur del país contra el
ejército Ruso y las milicias
separatistas de la región del Don vast
Polonia que había autorizado a comienzos
de enero el envío de los tanques
leopardo Ucrania dependía el visto bueno
de su vecina Alemania para concretar la
transferencia debido a que estos tanques
son de fabricación alemana por lo que
más temprano en una conferencia de
prensa El Primer Ministro polaco
aumentaba la presión sobre shorts
Alemania es el país más grande y debe
hacer una enorme contribución a esta
coalición conjunta de países que ayudan
a Ucrania hemos presentado esta
solicitud y esperamos una pronta
respuesta por supuesto ya estamos
entrenando a soldados ucranianos en
Polonia otros países también lo están
haciendo y Seguiremos haciéndolo
ahora con la autorización de Alemania
terceros países también podrán
transferir tanques leopardo a Ucrania en
Europa 10 países poseen este armamento
de los cuales Polonia y República Checa
ya dieron luz verde Rusia ha advertido
anteriormente que el envío de tanques de
guerra Ucrania por parte de occidente
generaría consecuencias catastróficas
los tanques leopard son considerados
claves para las maniobras terrestres y
en la actualidad son el mejor tanque
europeo